well joining us now is Dr Liam Fox
previously a member of the government
conservative MP for North Somerset so
much to talk to you about I wonder if I
might be able to ask you about energy
bills if that's okay
um we're just hearing from off gem that
vulnerable customers are being ripped
off by big energy companies in all sorts
of ways I'm sure that some of your
constituents are going to be affected by
that and not least those that are on
prepayment meters
um is there anything you can do about it
I think it's something that the big
energy companies need to look at the
government the taxpayers you and I are
putting in a lot of money to help
especially those on Lower incomes and I
think the energy companies need to be
doing the same to make sure that tariffs
and charges are as Fair as possible and
that the money that taxpayers putting in
will therefore go as far as possible
yeah um do you think the government is
doing enough I mean there were some
suggestions that the government
shouldn't get involved in in I mean
obviously they're coming up with a lot
of money but they shouldn't get involved
in support schemes to help customers
because that was too much of a nanny
State given that we're hearing from
off-gen that people for example people
on on prepayment meters are just
suffering at the hands of several of
these energy companies is it an area
where the government should perhaps look
at that again I think it's something
that Parliament will want to look at I'm
sure that select committees will want to
look at whether the public money that's
being put in an extra 26 billion that
the government announced last week which
is more than half of our defense budget
to put that in perspective that needs to
be used properly so I think that the
parliament all MPS will want to ensure
that that money is being used in an
effective way to help those especially
at lowest a lower income levels you know
previous prime minister said that we
would be helping people with Energy caps
for two years the new chancellor has
said we'll look at it again in April is
that right well it depends on what of
course is happening to Energy prices the
reason that we're having this high level
of support is because of the Russian
invasion of Ukraine and how stop oil and
gas prices around the world if those
prices start to fall again clearly we
don't want to be having taxpayer subsidy
where we don't really need to have that
because we've got lots of other
priorities where we could be spending
that money so it's always a balance
about where the government uses
taxpayers money uh you don't want to be
putting subsidies in unnecessarily but
the government will look at it and see
where we need to Target that support
we've seen some evidence of those global
prices in oil and gas beginning to fall
again
but it's anyone's guess over the winter
and what will happen we don't know how
severe the winter in Europe will be what
demand will be and what that will do for
prices none of us can predict that
something there is an area of expertise
here of course is brexit we're hearing
from senior European figures say it's
wishful thinking that we could get
closer to the EU when it comes to trade
deals without
um with a special deal without agreeing
to free movement of people yeah I'm sure
they're right and I think this idea of
first of all I think politically
reopening the debate on brexit is the
very last thing that we need at the
present time and this talk about a Swiss
relationship you know for the Swiss they
have to pay into the European budget
they have to accept free movement of
people and they have to accept European
laws over which they've got no control I
don't see that as being in line any in
any way shape or form
um with the spirit of our referendum or
our exit from the European Union I think
it's a political non-starter it's a
waste of everybody's energy and we
should just get on with the job in hand
you say get on with the job in hand but
we don't enough have enough people to
get on with the job in hand there are
hundreds of millions of job vacancies
and I think one and a half million job
vacancies at the moment yes but and we
also have a very large number of people
who are out of work or an even bigger
number of people who are not
economically active so what we're going
to do with it so well so one of the
interesting things about the budget and
something that a lot of us have been
talking about is is why so many people
have chosen not to work as we know a lot
of people from the age 55 bracket uh
onwards and have chosen not to work
since the pandemic I think we need to
try to understand why that is and try to
find if we can find attractive ways to
bring these people back into the economy
whether that's part-time or otherwise
then I think the other thing to remember
about brexit
and immigration is this that we are
needing to deal with illegal immigration
but the point of brexit wasn't to stop
immigration it was to give us control of
immigration and I think that we're there
are areas of the economy where we need
more skilled people more quickly that I
think that we should use those freedoms
of brexit to try to achieve that the
whole point of brexit was to give us
back control it wasn't to have any one
policy imposed upon us two questions as
a result of what you said there um if we
try to make if the government tries to
make uh coming back to work for the over
55 is more attractive and that doesn't
work do you do you go for less
attractive ways to get them to come back
to work no I think you're trying to
encourage people back into the world you
can't force people into the workforce
this is a free country that people
choose not to work and they've got the
savings for example they can look at
their at their benefits can't you well
if people are have savings and they're
not on benefits for example they're
they're entitled not to work if they can
afford to do so people who put money
aside I think we try to want to try to
encourage more people back into that
Workforce because
um if we don't have the domestic
Workforce you've got two choices the
jobs don't get done or you have to bring
them in from elsewhere and people need
to have to I think as a national uh
conversation we need to decide you know
which of these options is most
attractive to us we we do need to have a
growing economy and that means a
Workforce is becoming either bigger or
more productive or both
um but if we can't do that domestically
uh we can't just leave the jobs unfilled
no but we need a more skilled Workforce
or she was saying now that takes time
there are skilled workers in Europe who
could come and fill those jobs for now
yes and if you know as I said as I said
the point of brexit was to give us
control over migration and if we need so
you're not rejecting that idea to bring
skilled workers more skilled workers no
no I'm absolutely not and I think that
we need to use our freedoms to be able
to use
um those those uh those powers to be
able to match the requirements of our
economy with those skills that may Exist
Elsewhere what we can't have is free
movement with people where people are
coming to the UK who may not have the
skills that we want but ultimately
become able to use our public services
or our benefits
um the PM also said we're in control of
our borders now because we are no longer
attached to the EU but we still have to
deal with countries like France don't we
on a daily basis so we're just picking
and choosing well I think on the
question of migration I think we have to
have a wider view frankly of what the
problem is and I would say you can break
it into three parts you've got those who
are crossing from France into the UK at
the present time France has its own
problems because of the Schengen
agreement the free movement of people in
Europe effectively if you can get into
the southern border of Greece you can
get to Calais because there are no
restrictions across European borders and
then we've got a very big Global problem
largely I think because of the pandemic
where you've had a lot of dis of people
who have been uh displaced economically
by the pandemic looking for a better
life and of course we live in a world
now where if you're a young African with
a mobile phone you can see what
Prosperity looks like and if that's
being denied to you you will try to get
something better for yourself I think
that's a normal human reaction I think
therefore we have to think of the
Upstream if you like elements of that
migration problem including how do we
ensure that developing countries get
their fair share of prosperity and the
post-pandemic we're not putting them at
an economic disadvantage because of of
elements in the global trading system
it's it's a it's a it's a problem with a
lot of different layers and I think a
lot of the political debate is too
simplistic complex problems
as I would say as a doctor seldom have a
simple solution to them glad you brought
up the fact that you're a doctor I'm
reading in the paper today that um Rishi
sunak um
says that the NHS is in his blood but he
pays 250 pounds to see a doctor as soon
as possible he enrolls in an agency that
will do that for him how does he square
that Circle to say that you know he's in
his blood and the NHS is his number one
priority but if he's got an ache or a
pain he can just jump the queue well
he's judged by what he does in terms of
public policy I think that the
government is judged by what it does for
the NHS and how much money do what I say
not as I do no the government is judged
and politicians are judged by the public
policy and what they do for the NHS
we've seen record sums going into the
NHS the NHS has two particular problems
at the present time number one is
inflation so even with a big increase
being put in that that will eat that up
and the second is we've got a chronic
problem in the NHS with people being
unable to be discharged from our
hospitals yeah because the problems with
social care well it's partly that it's
partly I would also argue a lack of uh
capacity inside the NHS now it's a long
time since I worked in a hospital but
even then we had a problem with the
inability to discharge patients who were
perfectly ready to go from making
hospital my point my point is should
somebody who says that the NHS is in his
blood and he's responsible for where the
money goes be jumping the queue by
paying 250 quid to see a private doctor
rather than wasting a fortnight like the
rest of us well it's the Prime Minister
and the government are judged by what
they do for the NHS what they do with
the private monies is up to them but I
don't have private insurance but I don't
in any way think that people should not
do that if that's what they choose to do
and remember everybody does that even if
they're the Prime Minister well and what
does that say about the Optics well it
anyone is entitled to do that but this
is a free country and and it cannot be
that we tell some people that they
cannot do that the government is judged
by what it's doing for the NHS and the
NHS is getting a lot of extra money
we're trying to deal with those problems
of capacity in the NHS and the fact that
the NHS is suffering from a huge number
of job vacancies at the present time
which people are not going into so
that's not going to be helps nor does
the debate get help with some rich bloke
who is telling us how to live our lives
and yet and taxing us more and yet he
can jump the queue when it suits him
well the prime minister's job is to make
sure that the public provision of Health
in this country is as good as it can be
both with time as a Chancellor now as
prime minister we're seeing record sums
going into the NHS that's the job of
politicians appreciate how that might
not sit well with my viewers this
morning well lots of people in this
country will choose to use either the
savings or private Health policies to be
able to get Private health care every
time someone does that it's less strain
on the NHS I mean if you'd want to get
rid of Private health care you'll get an
even bigger stream on the NHS the
government's job is to make sure the NHS
is well run and is well funded and under
Rishi sunak and this government I'm
confident it will be so you don't think
for one second that people will find it
um they'll have to hold their nose when
they read about this story well people
will get Private health care through
their companies to the trade unions and
through the trade unions in some cases
so um I don't see why that's uh any
different as I said the job of the
government to make sure the NHS is well
run and it's well funded okay and that's
what's happening okay now I know
Scotland are not in the World Cup I'm
sorry to rub that in but how did you
find the games yesterday
well I'm a little worried that um Iran
could get two goals against England
and um I'm a bit I think they've got one
girl against Scotland though didn't they
last time you played them yeah that's
and it was a draw that is not a bar that
I would necessarily apply okay
um and I think that the world should be
disappointed
um with the draw so it's uh it's going
to be an interesting tournament there's
uh there's a lot to fight for still and
who's going to win I have no idea uh
Tina
um I haven't really have no idea as long
as it's not Argentina frankly
I don't really have any countries that I
don't want to win and you know
something that a lot of people have been
saying is um can we just talk about the
football and not try to politicize what
I was trying to do every single bit
um of it and if we can get back to sport
a sport yeah so much more helpful and
you know if we have fewer TV um
commentators lecturing us about climate
change and immigration and other issues
and actually still talk to us about
football I think a lot of viewers will
be a lot happier okay it's good to talk
to you Doctor as always thanks very much
indeed for joining us thank you